so jack dorsey first one twitter ceo
stepping down uh officially steps down
with his role effective immediately
dorsey co-founded twitter with evan
williams bistone and noah glass back in
2006 and served as a ceo until 2008 he
later returned to the ceo role in 2015
and former ceo dick costello stepped
down he has a net worth of approximately
11.8 billion dollars there's a lot of
talk about the importance of a company
being founder-led dorsey sent an email
to employees ultimately i believe that
severely uh limiting in a single point
of failure i've worked hard to ensure
this company can break away from its
founding and founders
dorsey will be replaced by twitter cto
parag agarwal uh your thoughts on this
move taking place yesterday
so i think dorsey's hated that company
for about 10 years now why do you say
that
why do you say that i mean he's at odds
with the company like here's the thing i
said before he's a communist who thinks
he's a libertarian and so he's got this
major conflict and that you know he
quotes mises and talks about bitcoin but
but ultimately the the behavior of
things like it's one thing to be
you know hey let's let's let's talk
about sound money and then but actually
i've got this platform that's known for
its political censorship and and and for
doing what the the communist party in
china asks for when when necessary and
and these different things and it's like
if you don't behave the same on friday
night as you do on sunday morning then i
don't like you as a person fundamentally
in fairness not that i i make you know
not that i want to be the guy defending
jack dorsey here but if you believe what
joe rogan has to say he's been
advocating for free speech on twitter
and he's been overruled by his own board
for years so much so that he tried to do
a spin-off called like twitter dark or
something like that where it was
basically going to be a you know twitter
and 4chan where anything goes free
speech up voting system um and he was
again
he was denied by his board so i mean if
you believe that story this is a guy
who's been eaten by his own success he
doesn't even have to say in his own
company
i don't know man when you're the captain
of a ship you
if the ship gets out of control i think
that's your fault like at what point
were the decisions made that allowed a
bunch of nasty social justice warriors
to be in charge of the whole company
like these these are a lot of little
decisions that led to that at some point
and so i think he's got to own that and
and i really i think that's a lot of lip
service because i think in theory he
doesn't want to lose his street cred as
like the cool guy with a nose ring
silicon valley right it's just the whole
thing it's like well i'm gonna be this
this disruptive libertarian guy but i'm
also very san francisco and everything
else and it's just it just
they can't be both and he didn't choose
so he's he's been riding the fence for a
decade trying to make twitter
outside of twitter he has a chance to
make it right though
which i i i'm excited for jack dorsey's
second act if if he can come out and do
what he wanted to do if there's a a
chance to do a secondary
you know social media channel that that
promotes free speech he can he can save
his legacy
and we'll see i don't know
the thing that he pretty much put out
there and i that my question is how big
of a concern is making money to him or
increasing his net worth because i think
his net worth is what 12 billion dollars
somewhere around that and he said that
he'd want his sole focus now to be on
square and obviously
everything that square is doing in the
crypto space and it's gonna be backed by
bitcoin and
i mean he
twitter i think is down double digits
percentages here he looks at someone
like zuk who's worth over a hundred
billion dollars they're up 20 this year
and he looks at square and says that's a
better opportunity to make more money
how much of a motivation it is to
basically increase his net worth i it's
hard to know i i think square
uh you know square's a big proponent of
the lightning network and and the whole
btc narrative they're part of what's
called the crypto open patent alliance
which i think is another nasty cabal of
people that just want to control things
similar like connected to the barry
silbert people and all of this like
there's a group of people that want to
again pretend that they're disruptors
pretend that they're libertarians
pretend that they're gonna do all these
big things and ultimately it's like yeah
but everybody behind me like yeah i'm
going to lunch with world bankers and
and doing all this other stuff and
really it's i i think it's a larp i
think the whole thing is like look man
i'm cool you can you can use square and
pretend it's bitcoin and and all this
stuff like but keep using square here
it's
i think it's a money all of our
employees are going to have critical
theory training and yeah exactly right i
have a question for you so let me tell
you let me tell you what i just did
right now while you guys were going out
i was doing a little bit of research hey
can you uh uh pull up this article type
in jack dorsey says trump's twitter ban
was right decision this is an npr
article i want to read this to you and
then i want to answer a question about
what you said and what you said that you
guys uh made me think uh trump's
uh donald trumos from uh paris
nice to meet you boy yeah right there
all right so check this out so you just
said you just said uh you brought up uh
uh uh you know him uh you know he's the
captain of the ship he's got this option
all this other stuff and you said rogan
et cetera et cetera he says look i'd
love to have some kind of a second
option you know twitter and i remember
when that conversation took place uh
what percentage of twitter do you think
he owns
i don't even know i want you to guess it
i want you to guess what percentage do
you think he owns if i had a spit ball
i'd probably say 20 or 30 30 okay
20 or 30 what do you think he owns i'd
say a little less than that okay so
here's what i want you to type i want
you to type jack dorsey
total shares of twitter and look what
comes up you guys are all going to be
shell shocked
jack dorsey total shares of twitter okay
twerk
twitter there you go ready 22 million
shares which is only three percent of
twitter three percent he's a nobody
so here's what this means when you're
three percent okay steve jobs got fired
even though he owned most shares when he
got a board the board is a board you
ain't got nothing you listen you you can
be whoever you are so for us to go that
position i don't think he has as much
influence as you think he does to do
what he did with trump or all this other
stuff he may have an opinion i don't
think it's a good idea but the board is
gonna i'm in these board meetings all
the time and believe me i kind of know
how these things work so now go to the
other article what he said about trump
so
uh so jack dorsey was uh says trump's
twitter ban was right decision but
worries about president so go down and
see what he tweets out he says i do not
celebrate or feel pride in heaven uh to
ban uh donald trump for twitter or how
we got here after clear warning we take
the uh this action we we the board made
a decision with the best information we
had based on threats to physical safety
both on and off twitter was this correct
and he opens it up and people are going
back and forth yes no maybe whatever now
deep down inside did he want to take him
off or on i don't know
did it make sense to do it or not i
don't know
was most of his board probably an
anti-trump board i would be willing to
bet 99 of the board can't stand trump i
don't think they're gonna have a you
know for example kellyanne conway sits
on twitter's board that's probably not
going to be happening anytime soon or
ted cruz or any of those guys right so
is there a part of it where you know
the guys got a difficult job they
started a company that to be honest with
you is probably one of the most powerful
companies that determine elections uh
you go immediately to find out what
debates are taking place issues taking
place immediate reaction it's a very
very kind of pulse of america right i
don't know i mean it's a pretty powerful
company you know trump wouldn't become a
president without twitter take twitter
out trump's not the president just so
you know that yeah if twitter's not
there trump's not the president and
hillary clinton's the president so for
the people that hate him as much as they
do you may want to thank twitter because
without twitter there's no trump hillary
clinton would have been your president
that's one part now what he does next i
don't know uh you know whether he is a
communist whether he's a libertarian i
have no idea uh what next moves he's
going to make i i i
the real question now becomes who's the
next guy taking over and who sits on
twitter's board can you pull up who sits
on twitter's board well it's interesting
that you say you know that uh he was a
nobody too because his first time on
rogan it was really off-putting i forget
her name there was a woman very very
intelligent woman but it was very clear
that she knew the day-to-day operations
of what was going on behind the scenes
and the decisions being made and he
didn't he kept deferring to her to
answer rogan's questions okay so because
he wasn't the ceo for like five all
right so check this out so here's the
board of twitter brett taylor
independent board chair president chief
operating officer salesforce okay cool
so that's from salesforce salesforce is
mark benninghoff mark benninghoff bought
time magazine uh that's an anti-trump
guy that's a liberal left side
agrawal we know what position he's at
now and where he was at politically he
is not necessarily the biggest supporter
of freedom of speech i don't know if you
guys seen what he tweeted out about
freedom of speech have you seen what he
said about freedom of speech he uh he's
conflicted with freedom of speech he
doesn't think it needs to be
as open as possible you may want to pull
up his name type in agrawal tweet
freedom it's kind of not a gray area
conversation you're either for freedom
of speech or you're not freedom of
speech tweet
speech tweet uh uh pull that up so this
is the board okay go
uh runs on one set to come okay there
you go click on that one right there fox
business the bottom uh uh he says one
said
uh not to be rounded by from okay keep
going up keep going up keep going up uh
uh
uh go up a little bit higher until we
find the tweet uh okay
all right go back and just go to images
go back and type in images it'll come up
if you type in images
if they are not going to make a
distinction between muslims and
extremists then why should i distinguish
between white
that's a little people concerning if
they're not going to make a distinction
between muslims and extremists then why
should i distinguish between white
people and racist so the verdict is
still out we don't know who this guy is
anyways the board chose him jack dorsey
did not choose him the board chosen now
jack says in his email this was my first
option as well this is who i wanted he's
my first round draft pick go back to the
board of twitter i'm actually just
curious right now at this point
on who sits on the board so then you got
mimi senior vice president private um
partnership at mastercard okay cool jack
dorsey got it which by the way in may
he's stepping down from the board as
well
uh co-seal at silver lake you know
founder jefferson lucky voice group
former co-founder managing director last
executive former executive chairman of
twitter cole professor at stanford makes
sense good university general partners
at cinema development champions
china by the way
who's that faithfully
makes sense ceo for someone with inc
former chairman board of directors at
alliance bernstein holding company okay
so that's who how many people in total
i think it's it's either nine or eleven
go up let's see one two three four five
six seven eight nine it's nine okay is
there
how many is it important to distinguish
between nine versus eleven versus seven
doesn't make a difference three five
seven nine eleven thirteen fifteen it's
it's whatever the odd number it's always
an announcement how does somebody give
up 97 of their company that's like
that's that's if you keep raising a lot
of money well you have to know here's a
question for you what is the business
model for twitter to make money you
actually think how many times have you
spent money on twitter it's only
advertisers yep okay so you have to know
the business model isn't really a
business model like assume they're
selling information you need a lot of
money they paid a lot of money so data
the new currency to sustain like what do
you think youtube was sold for do you
know what youtube was sold for no it's a
billion dollars seven
i thought it was more than one billion
dollars it's a big billion dollars so
because youtube eventually got so big
where the guys didn't have advertising
figured out you don't have capacity for
servers it keeps crashing so you're like
dude i'm gonna go raise some money you
can't afford to do this anymore so i'm
not surprised it's worth three percent
so
jack dorsey is not as influential as
people think within twitter community
that's the point i'm trying to make with
the bigger lesson is the the founder
is not as influential as
as you would assume it depends on what
phase at one phase it really depends it
depends on the company structured why it
grew into what it did
this is this is why i would i would
again put the put the pressure back on
jack dorsey though and say hey man the
company looks the way it looks because
of your executive leadership over the
last
15-ish years you know like that's
again
like
russell brooke has never sold a drug in
his life but he created a platform where
people sold drugs and arms and now he's
spending the rest of his life in jail
yeah nobody's saying the onus isn't on
him yeah you know like yesterday i'm
talking to jack carr i don't know if you
know jack carr is the navy seal who
wrote all those books new york time
bestsellers and i asked him a question i
said okay so we talked about afghanistan
i said here's a question for you i said
take the general the army the general
air force the general marines did you
take all the main generals of whatever
the four branches are that we have right
and the president commander-in-chief
says let's get out of afghanistan okay
you're on the ground and you're saying
this ain't the right strategy right
there's no way this is the right move
we're making we're going to leave all
this [ __ ] to the taliban they're going
to come and ruin people's lives here in
afghanistan 20 years we've been working
here i follow orders i said but here's
the question no no that's not the
question the question is
those
nobody becomes the general of the army
marines air force or navy and you don't
have a strong personality nobody and by
the way the general of any of these
organizations it's not like you're a yes
man person right let me sit there and
say hey i'm sorry guys this is a shitty
strategy
i'm gonna have to push back hey
president this is not a good move i'm
telling you my suggestion is we do this
right there's gotta be pushback you're
there you know more than the president
does you're trying to tell him he's not
the right move right okay so
but the president says what here's what
we're doing to me
this becomes like who is really running
a company on twitter is it the generals
running it in this instance if you see
twitter's interview with jack and the
other lady that was there it seemed like
the operator operators are running it
jack's not really as involved he was
more the figurehead so sometimes you're
more distant you no longer have the kind
of influence that you had you just kind
of are there on the board because you
have certain special information that
maybe others don't have but you kind of
like listen
it's cool jack and jack's more saying
what do you guys think what are you
guessing what do you guys think i don't
on what to do so i don't know i don't
know how much of it is him running it i
think this was kind of coming uh it'll
be interesting to see what this guy does
next he's definitely not going to be
going away i don't think but we'll see
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]